[Music]
so I want to set the scene for what Jane
Jensen and Michelle then we'll discuss
by thinking about different conceptions
of inequality and what these different
conceptions of inequality might mean for
public policy and I'm going to argue in
favor of adopting more expansive
conceptions of inequality so we all know
that we live in an era of rising
inequality this figure draws on a famous
book by Thomas Piketty and the chart
shows the share of national income going
to people in the top one tenth of one
percent in Canada and on the right hand
side also the Gini index a well-known
measure of inequality my parents that's
my father were born in a moment of high
inequality I was born at a time when
inequality was falling I was born in
Montreal I was a very chubby baby and
many people here were born as I look
around somewhat later and of course just
at the time when inequality of various
sorts has been rising quite dramatically
but these facts alone this kind of chart
doesn't tell us as much as we want to
know about well-being or indeed about
how to improve well-being do the sums
that Galen Weston or Paul Desmarais earn
every year really matter to us I mean I
care more about whether Jane Jensen
earns more money than I do every year
but even that causes me only a small bit
of mental anguish
much more important than relative income
I think is absolute income namely the
incomes earned by people around the
median and you can see the arrow points
to this part of the diagram median
incomes in Canada have not varied very
dramatically over the last 30 years and
so here the news is not especially good
lower level incomes which is a bar just
have risen slightly more and that's good
news but though
poverty rates in Canada are falling they
remain alarmingly high as I think we all
know here especially among indigenous
people moreover the stagnation of median
income the stagnation of average income
is a reflection of deeper economic
problems problems that aren't going to
be easy to solve so we know for instance
that wages are tied to productivity but
productivity in Canada is rising much
less quickly than it is in the u.s. to
the south and for the first time in
decades a gap has opened up between the
rate of growth of productivity and the
rate of growth of wages I think this
diagram is one of the most important
that we can see today it means that
ordinary people are no longer securing
the fruits of their labor in the way
that they did for decades in this
country and in the u.s. the gap is
larger in the US but it's apparent and
present in Canada as well
now in order to understand the impact of
income inequality on well being I think
we also need to take an additional step
we need to realize that at the same time
that incomes are becoming more unequal
an increasing number of basic goods on
which people depend to maintain their
style of life a basic set of goods that
were once provided more or less free or
at low cost often provided as public
goods by government an increasing number
of those goods are now becoming
commodities for which
people are being charged and the prices
of those commodities are going up so
there's a kind of commoditization here
that's important college tuition is an
example this is Canadian college tuition
since 1992 ition in Canadian
universities has tripled
partly because governments are funding a
smaller share of the cost of tuition so
the burden borne by low-income families
in particular has risen dramatically and
of course education is especially
important because it's the means to rise
on the social ladder but the same thing
is true of home energy energy used to
heat and light the home has become
increasingly expensive in Canada over
the past 20 years more than a million
Canadians now spend more than 10 percent
of their income on heating energy light
alone so the result to use a kind of
technical term of social science is a
double whammy
just as incomes are becoming more
unequal access to basic goods is being
increasingly rationed by income and I
think this is something all of us who
study these phenomena need to think
about so what do these observations
imply for people concerned about social
justice concerned about social
well-being I think we can draw three
tentative conclusions here from this
part of what I want to say first
I think top incomes don't matter that
much what we should really be thinking
about is the trajectory of average
incomes the incomes of ordinary people
at the median and below the median
second to get this to work second I
think the solutions to inequality don't
lie entirely in redistribution by
governments that's what we normally
think about but we should also be
concerned about what Jacob hacker calls
predistribution
that is how the institutions of the
Canadian economy distribute market
come market income before taxes and
transfers and to some extent this turns
on government regulations regulations
about minimum wages regulations that
require firms to provide decent pension
Xand benefits but it also depends on
whether firms act in the interests of
their stakeholders as well as in the
interest of their shareholders and on
whether and that depends to some extent
on whether trade unions are strong
enough to pressure them to do so and on
that front the news isn't particularly
good here finally these observations
direct our attention I think to the
issue of what I'd call public provision
namely the extent to which governments
are willing to deliver public goods and
to deliver them at low cost I'm thinking
about sports facilities libraries
internet access public transport I mean
consider London England for instance
which where I usually am in the spring a
short ride on the London subway the tube
costs $9 Canadian these days in case any
of you were thinking of going there this
spring but at the same time
public transit buses and subway are free
for all London residents over the age of
60 think what a difference that makes
but think that that difference applies
to some people and not to others so
public provision in which Canada has
always been more successful in the u.s.
I might add is another key feature of
inequality and what we might be doing
about it okay so before closing I want
to take a second step I've got only 15
minutes here towards expanding our
conception of inequality and I want to
move beyond income to think about other
forms of inequality and how they impinge
on well-being so how might we do this
well one way to do this is to adopt what
members of the CFR successful societies
program have begun to call a
capabilities approach to well-being and
this is elaborated on our first book I
can only touch on it briefly here but I
want to say
something about it the basic idea is
that all people face a common set of
life challenges finding housing finding
a spouse caring for children finding a
job and the like and to these life
challenges every person brings a certain
set of capabilities so each person's
well-being depends to some extent on the
balance between the life challenges that
person faces and the capabilities the
person brings to those life challenges
so the question of interest for us of
course is where do those capabilities
come from and of course we know that
some of them reside in qualities of
character that are nurtured during
childhood and this means that the
circumstances for early childhood
development are very important in this
context what a person's capabilities are
also conditioned by our position within
a broader set of social and economic
structures a broader set of social and
economic relations and by virtue of this
her position in this set of economic
relations a person can call upon certain
economic resources for her capabilities
of course the classic example is income
incomes a multi-purpose instrument that
can be used as we all know to cope with
a variety of life challenges but
workplace autonomy also matters here the
security of employment also matters here
whether you can leave your job to take
care of a sick child makes a big
difference to your well-being and in
much the same way the members of this
program suggest that every person
occupies certain positions within a
parallel set of social structures that
provide that person with certain social
resources so these structures include
social networks namely ties to friends
and family
might help with finding a job might help
with finding housing or caring for a
child might provide emotional support in
the context of sickness and these
structures these social structures also
specify the social status that a person
enjoys and status is important because
people often call upon their status in
order to secure the cooperation of
others in life endeavors that's why I'm
wearing a tie today in order to
emphasize my social status so you'll
accept that answers I give to anybody's
questions and status is dependent to
some extent on the collective imaginary
of the community I can't say much about
this at the moment but the broad set of
narratives that tell us who belongs to
the community and what the members of
the community oh one another so the
basic idea should be pretty clear here
although it didn't isn't very clear in
my slide a person's well-being does not
simply depend on her place within the
distribution of income it also depends
on her place within a distribution of
social resources not just economic
resources but social resources and this
is important because research I've done
for the successful societies program
shows that social resources are also
distributed unequally across societies
this slide shows you people divided by a
standard set of social classes and it
gives you measures for the different
kinds of social ties in this case social
networks how dense are the social
networks that each person experiences
there's a kind of conventional wisdom
which says that well the wealthy can use
money to solve their problems the poor
don't have money but they use social
networks to solve their problems but
what this kind of figure suggests to you
is that in fact it's the wealthy who
have better dense or larger social
networks and those at lower levels of
income lack not only income but they
lack the social ties that are a critic
social resource let me close again by
asking what are the implications of this
somewhat broader capabilities
perspective on well-being what are the
implications for people concerned about
social justice and social well-being as
a whole well first we should all be
concerned not only about the
distribution of material resources but
about the distribution of social
resources namely about the access that
different kinds of people have to social
networks and the various kinds of status
conferred on different kinds of people
by the collective imaginaries of our
society the collective imaginary of
Quebec or of Canada and the successful
societies program has shown that these
resources impinge not only on people's
general well-being but also on their
health and if you want later on I can
show you some figures about that
secondly I think this observation
implies that the efforts of civic
organizations which many of you here
represent to build social networks among
the less affluent and to improve the
social status assigned to marginalized
communities like indigenous peoples
those efforts to build social networks
and to alter the status hierarchy may be
as important to overall well-being and
the well-being of the people you're
serving as efforts to increase the
material resources to those communities
this is not a substitute for material
resources but it's something we
shouldn't forget and finally these
observations have some important
implications for public policy
governments as we all know are often
fixated on the distribution of material
resources but public policies can also
enhance or erode the distribution of
social resources and governments often
do that as a byproduct an inadvertent
byproduct of policies aimed in other
direction
so if changes in a particular set of
zoning laws in one part of Montreal may
have some benefits maybe it in some ways
it contributes to the gentrification of
a community and maybe that has economic
benefits if those changes in zoning laws
eliminate fast-food restaurants in that
area some may see that as desirable but
that could well be as I well know from
my own community that could well
eliminate the gathering points at which
the elderly in that community get
together every morning and forged their
own social networks so well-meaning
policies described mainly in terms of
their material effects often have
unintended consequences with regard to
the distribution of social resources
labor regulations designed to improve
job mobility may well in some ways help
people secure jobs but at the same time
they may also isolate people take them
away from their ties to families and
friends that can be a very important
part of their social well-being in other
words we need to think about public
policy making in a somewhat new way as a
process of social resource creation we
need to recognize that public policies
can enhance and they can enrolled erode
they can alter the distribution of
social resources and policymakers should
be attentive I think to this side and as
citizens we should all be attentive to
this side of public policymaking we all
worry about the conservation of natural
resources we should also be worried
about the conservation of social
resources and I think that poses an
agenda of some importance for many
governments including governments in
Quebec thank you
[Applause]
[Music]